Salut à tous, aujourd'hui j'ai une grande nouvelle  : on vient de dépasser les 100000 abonnés sur la chaîne YouTube.
En plus d'être une bonne nouvelle, c'est surtout un mensonge.
Ce qui est vrai c'est que le mercredi c'est le jour des astuces
et qu'aujourd'hui je vous donne 3 astuces pour détecter un menteur.
Premièrement le regard.
Il y a une croyance populaire qui dit que quand quelqu'un vous regarde bien dans les yeux, c'est qu'il dit la vérité.
C'est complètement l'inverse. C'est complètement anormal que le regard soit figé.
Quand quelqu'un vous regarde droit dans les yeux tout le temps, tout le temps ou LUI parle en tout cas,
il y a de fortes chances que cette personne là soit en train de mentir.
Un menteur en train de proférer son mensonge vous regarde droit dans les yeux,
d'une part pour avoir l'air franc et d'autre part pour vérifier que vous gobez son mensonge en fait.
Il essaye de voir sur votre visage si vous êtes en train de croire en ce qu'il dit ou si vous êtes en train de douter.
Nan j'vous jure que je fume pas. C'était un pote qu'était avec moi et du coup,
c'est pour ça que je sens la fumée de cigarette parce que lui, ah la la, qu'est ce qu'il fume.
C'est tout ! Oh la la, il fait froid aujourd'hui hein ?
Un autre signe du mensonge très pertinent, c'est la position du regard
quand la personne est en train de vous parler en fait.
Quand on raconte une histoire, quelque chose qui s'est passé à quelqu'un,
on est obligé de replonger dans ses souvenirs.
Y a des positions très précises qui nous sont apprises par la PNL
via la programmation neuro linguistique.
Imaginez des pointillés sur mon visage,
je pourrais les faire mais j'ai pas envie de frotter après.
Cette partie là de mon visage va correspondre à ce qu'on appelle la créativité.
Cette partie là va correspondre à ma mémoire.
Si mes yeux vont en haut à gauche, donc en haut à droite pour vous qui me regardez,
c'est que je suis dans le visuel souvenir,
c'est-à-dire que je cherche un souvenir visuel dans ma tête.
Essayez par exemple de visualiser les vêtements que vous aviez hier sur vous
et instinctivement votre regard va monter en haut à gauche
pour aller chercher ce souvenir visuel.
Mais si mon regard était parti en haut à droite,
donc en haut à gauche pour vous qui me regardez,
ça aurait voulu dire que j'étais en train de créer un souvenir visuel, donc quelque chose qui n'existe pas.
Si par exemple je vous demande d'imaginer une girafe volante à pois bleus,
pour vous la représenter, il va falloir que vous créiez l'image dans votre cerveau
donc vous allez aller chercher par là-haut.
Pour les sons, c'est pareil mais ça marche sur une ligne droite.
Juste ici, ça veut dire que je suis en train de me rappeler un son.
Mais si ça part de ce côté là et toujours en ligne droite,
ça veut dire que je suis en train de créer un son dans ma tête,
un son que je ne connaissais pas ou un son qui n'existait pas,
voire même une conversation qui n'a jamais existé.
Ce qui se passe en bas du visage après n'a rien à voir avec le mensonge.
Si je regarde juste comme ça en fait, en oblique,
c'est que je suis sur un dialogue interne : je suis en train par exemple de réfléchir à ce que je vais répondre.
De ce côté là, on est sur le kinesthésique,
c'est-à-dire que je suis en train de ressentir une émotion, une sensation, ce genre de chose.
L'ensemble est très intéressant parce que quand quelqu'un vous raconte un mensonge,
tout n'est pas mensonger dans son histoire.
Ça part souvent d'une vérité et y a des éléments par contre qui sont complètement faux.
Après, y a les gros mythos qui racontent une histoire fausse de A à Z.
Mais tous les mouvements oculaires qui vont se passer,
vous allez pourvoir les traduire pour voir si ça colle en fait avec l'histoire
ou détecter à quel endroit précisément la personne est en train de mentir.
Résumé, vous allez apprécier mes talents de dessinateur, ça c'est certain,
voici un visage qui est juste en face de vous.
Si les yeux vont par là, c'est qu'on est sur du visuel mémoire,
par ici, c'est de l'auditif mémoire,
par ici on est sur un dialogue interne.
Si le regard part par là, on est sur de la sensation, du ressenti.
De ce côté là, on est sur un auditif créé,
et par en haut, on est sur un visuel créé.
La dernière méthode, c'est par pour détecter le mensonge, c'est pour piéger le menteur.
Si vous penser que la personne est en train de mentir
mais que vous n'êtes pas certain à 100% malgré les 2 techniques précédentes,
ou si vous voulez mettre le menteur mal à l'aise et lui prouver qu'il est en train de mentir,
la technique ultime pour ça : vous lui demandez de raconter la même histoire,
le même mensonge mais à l'envers, de la fin jusqu'au début.
Comme le menteur est en train de créer son histoire au fur et à mesure
et trouve une logique dans l'histoire dans ce sens là,
il va s'en rappeler plus ou moins, il va être capable de la ressortir.
Par contre c'est impossible pour lui de le faire de manière fluide et à l'envers.
N'y allez pas comme une brute non plus, vous pouvez juste poser des questions :
Il c'était passé quoi à la fin ? Ah oui d'accord, et juste avant ? Oui, ok.
Mais toi t'étais arrivé quand ?
Et vous allez vraiment voir la galère et le stress sur la personne.
Si la personne était en train de vous mentir,
de toute manière vous allez voir à quel point elle est en galère, à quel point elle est stressée.
Docteur House disait tout le monde ment.
Bon c'est pas complètement faux, on fait tous des petits mensonges au quotidien
donc n'en voulez jamais trop à quelqu'un qui vous a menti.
Si c'est un mensonge juste pour enjoliver un petit peu sa vie etc, c'est pas bien grave.
Après c'est différent si c'est quelque chose qui vous créé une embrouille à vous.
Bien sûr, nous on va pas se mentir :
si cette astuce vous a plu vous mettez un petit pouce en l'air et puis voilà !
Ça c'est sincère ! Et vous pouvez vous abonner évidemment ou commenter.
Je lis tous les commentaires, tous, tous, tous, tout le temps !
Plus ça va plus je lis des commentaires.
Demain pour le vidéo de "je dis ce que je veux", je vais vous parler d'un sosie.
Apparemment, je suis le sosie de quelqu'un, je l'ai appris dans les commentaires récemment.
Je suis allé voir, ça m'a ... ça m'a rempli de douleur parce que c'est vrai !
Je vous fais une annonce à la fin de la vidéo pour le live qu'on va organiser.
D'ici là, portez vous bien. Rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain Mental Vlog. Ciao !
Le Mental Vlog, c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Tous les jours, je mets une vidéo pendant un an.
J'ai commencé le 1er janvier, je finirai le 31 décembre.
J'avais un objectif à 2500 abonnés
qu'on vient de cramer puisqu'on est arrivé à 9000 abonnés
depuis que Pierre Croce m'a invité à faire une vidéo avec lui.
J'avais dit qu'à 2500 abonnés, on ferait un live tous ensemble
donc je me suis dit ok, on va tous se rejoindre sur la page Facebook Fabien Olicard et on fera le live.
Et je viens de découvrir qu'un live Facebook, ça ne peut faire que 30 minutes, donc c'est pas hyper intéressant.
J'ai donc porté mon choix sur Periscope.
Donc vous pouvez me rajouter sur Twitter ou sur Periscope :
c'est fabienolicard tout attaché, sur tous mes réseaux sociaux d'ailleurs,
et ce samedi, le samedi 2 avril à 16h, je lance le live des Mentalo,
pour pouvoir prendre le temps de discuter.
On peut parler de la chaîne, on peut parler du mentalisme,
on peut parler des spectacles, on peut parler de n'importe quoi en fait ... n'importe quoi !
Le but c'est qu'on se retrouve.
Pour pas le rater, vous pouvez déjà me rajouter sur Periscope ou sur Twitter directement,
ou sur Facebook aussi puisque je rajouterai le lien sur la fanpage.
Voilà, c'était la fin de l'annonce. Ciao !